accueil chaleureux pour nawal madame y
l'humoriste présentait son tout premier
film à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est tout pour moi raconte l'histoire
d'une jeune bruxelloise une fiction
autobiographique 1995 bruxelles
à droite c'est moi lilas et saveurs
c'était le début des ennuis
j'ai pas hésité à aller chercher dans
mon histoire personnelle de temps en
temps à aller puiser dans des événements
qui me sont réellement arrivé et
puis et puis parfois fictionné parce que
c'est compliqué de raconter sa propre
histoire
je voulais prendre un recul et puis
surtout qu à des pertes de ma vie qui
ont été beaucoup plus longue dans la
galère par exemple 12 ans de galère j'ai
déchiré vos passeports
je vais vous envoyer hooglede-gits ma
mère et vous allez faire d'humour que
j'aurais cactus mais quinze ans après
j'étais toujours à fond j'avais qu'une
idée en tête ont tenté ma chance à part
une première expérience derrière et
devant la caméra
un premier film pour l'artiste belge
comme pour la plupart du casting est
toujours où je voulais que les gens
puissent se projeter et s'identifier
c'est un lourd challenge et parce que
j'ai eu cinq semaines pour tourner ce
film là les journées étaient intensive
on a tourné sept minutes jour du film
c'est s'est laissé le rythme d'un
téléfilm
il y avait beaucoup de décors beaucoup
personnage il fallait qu'on s'attache
aux personnages secondaires autant que
les propres autant que les personnages
principaux
c'est tout pour moi sera dans les salles
le 29 novembre prochain
le film parle de danse de one man show
mais c'est aussi une histoire d'amour et
celui de sa famille une success story
pour un message toujours prononcée
à part cette roma